Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Quello che vedete qui
è un evento accaduto nel 2001.
Che cos'è successo nel 2001
di così importante?
Beh, è stata pubblicata la prima sequenza
del DNA della nostra specie:
del DNA umano.
Vedete due riviste, Nature e Science,
tra le più prestigiose al mondo,
che hanno pubblicato la sequenza del DNA.
Che cosa vuol dire
che è stato sequenziato il nostro DNA?
Significa che i tre miliardi
e duecentomila paia di nucleotidi
che compongono il nostro genoma
sono stati messi in fila.
Che cos'è il DNA, fondamentalmente?
Forse lo citiamo molto spesso,
ma nel dettaglio, magari, ai più sfugge.
È un polimero in cui due filamenti,
appunto, di nucleotidi si susseguono,
e, nel caso del nostro genoma,
tre punto due per dieci
alla nona paia di basi
si susseguono a costituire il nostro DNA.
Naturalmente non in un'unica molecola,
perché questo DNA è spezzettato.
È spezzettato, come vedete qua,
nelle nostre ventitré copie di cromosomi.
E poi, in questo DNA,
che cos'è che veramente ci interessa?
Ci interessa, dal punto di vista
soprattutto farmacologico
soltanto tutto quanto questo DNA,
oppure ci sono delle porzioni,
di questo DNA, che ci interessano?
Beh, quello che a noi
interessa veramente sono i geni,
cioè le porzioni codificanti del DNA.
Che cosa codificano?
Codificano per proteine.
Tenete presente che soltanto
l'1,4 percento
del nostro genoma codifica per proteine.
Il restante novantotto
virgola sei percento
è stato sempre chiamato per molti anni,
nella letteratura internazionale,
"Junk DNA," DNA spazzatura,
perché l'uomo naturalmente disprezza
tutto quello che non capisce.
Gli evoluzionisti, invece,
ci hanno insegnato
quanto sia rilevante questo DNA
che non codifica per proteine.
Ma a noi, oggi,
interessano soltanto i geni,
ed interessano soltanto le proteine
che essi sono in grado di codificare.
Naturalmente, tenete presente
che, ovviamente, molto del lavoro
sul DNA era stato fatto.
Che cosa vuol dire che il DNA
contiene un'informazione genetica?
Significa semplicemente che c'è un codice,
il codice genetico,
il codice dei tre nucleotidi,
della tripletta,
che codifica, attraverso
un processo biochimico complesso,
che è la trascrizione e la traduzione,
codifica appunto per proteine.
Perché ci interessano
così tanto le proteine?
Perché la natura ha deciso
di salvaguardare
questo tipo d'informazione
e non il colesterolo, e non gli zuccheri?
Beh, perché, prima di tutto,
le proteine sono strutturali,
quindi costituiscono parte
del nostro organismo;
ma soprattutto perché
gli enzimi sono proteine,
e gli enzimi sono formidabili macchine
che sono in grado di trasformare
un sacco di cose,
modificandole, distruggendole,
sintetizzandole.
Quindi noi, sostanzialmente,
grazie agli enzimi siamo esseri viventi.
Che cosa abbiamo imparato
dal genoma, dal progetto genoma umano?
Beh, che ci sono, appunto,
tre miliardi di paia di basi,
che 1,4 percento viene trascritto -
Questo è un dato
abbastanza interessante:
abbiamo soltanto 25-30 mila geni.
Un tempo pensavamo di possederne
chissà quanti, centomila,
perché ci ritenevamo
molto più intelligenti
rispetto ad altre specie.
Probabilmente la complessità
e l'intelligenza
non risiedono semplicemente
nel numero di geni.
Ci sono ben 1.278 famiglie di proteine,
di cui soltanto 94 appartengono,
appunto, ai vertebrati.
Ma qual è la grande informazione
che abbiamo, per così dire, espanso,
qualche cosa già sapevamo,
ma questo concetto si è espanso
con il Progetto Genoma Umano.
Che non esiste un genoma umano,
ma che esistono i genomi umani.
In questa stanza non c'è nessuno
che ha la stessa sequenza di DNA
per i 30 mila geni.
I 30 mila geni sono diversi
da individuo ad individuo,
a meno che in questa stanza
non ci siano due gemelli monozigotici.
Allora, in questo caso,
il loro DNA è, effettivamente,
assolutamente identico.
Quindi, che cosa sono queste differenze?
Queste differenze di sequenza
prendono il nome di polimorfismi.
Sono variazioni assolutamente normali,
non sono delle mutazioni
sono variazioni assolutamente normali
all'interno del nostro genoma
che ci distinguono tutti
gli uni dagli altri.
Quindi, per esempio,
[in] un gruppo di persone
come noi questo pomeriggio,
in una posizione precisa del genoma,
nel contesto di un gene,
io ho una timina,
un altro soggetto ha una citosina.
I polimorfismi genetici sono molteplici.
Chi si occupa, appunto, di evoluzione
li conosce molto meglio del farmacologo,
ma il farmacologo
si interessa, sostanzialmente,
a due tipi di polimorfismi,
cioè il polimorfismo a singolo nucleotide
e la copy number variation.
Il polimorfismo a singolo nucleotide
è questa cosa qua, cioè appunto
un nucleotide di differenza.
Vedete, questa è la struttura di un gene.
In giallo vedete i cosiddetti esoni,
cioè le porzioni del gene
che effettivamente contengono
le triplette nucleotidiche
che codificano per gli amminoacidi.
Allora, se io ho questo polimorfismo,
ovviamente quello che può accadere
in termini di proteina
è che questa proteina
potrebbe avere un amminoacido diverso,
perché ho cambiato
la tripletta nucleotidica.
Se questa proteina fosse un enzima
potrebbe metabolizzare di più,
o metabolizzare di meno,
determinate sostanze.
La copy number variation, invece,
è qualche cosa di un pochino
più grossolano.
È stato scoperto che, sostanzialmente,
pezzi del nostro DNA,
anche 100 mila,
un milione di paia di basi,
in alcuni individui
possono essere presenti in più copie,
o in altri individui
possono essersi perse.
Allora, se questi pezzi di DNA
contengono dei geni,
ci possono essere
dei soggetti che, per esempio,
hanno tre copie dello stesso gene
sul cromosoma, invece di uno.
Oppure, se l'hanno perso,
hanno perso il gene,
quindi hanno perso la capacità
di sintetizzare quella proteina.
Facciamo il passaggio successivo,
ed iniziamo a parlare di farmacologia.
Il farmacologo, naturalmente,
è molto interessato
a queste variazioni genetiche,
perché ha il forte sospetto che,
nella diversa risposta ai farmaci,
il nostro assetto genetico
giochi un ruolo
assolutamente fondamentale.
E siccome noi adesso il genoma
abbiamo imparato molto bene a leggerlo,
e queste differenze le possiamo
identificare molto rapidamente,
forse ne possono conseguire,
per la terapia,
dei vantaggi assolutamente fondamentali.
Banalmente, che cosa succede
quando prendiamo
una compressa di un farmaco?
Consideriamo solo la via
di somministrazione orale.
Il farmaco viene introdotto
nell'intestino,
viene assorbito attraverso gli enterociti,
passa nel torrente ematico
e il primo filtro che incontra
è il filtro epatico.
Perché l'ho chiamato filtro?
Perché qua ci sono i famosi enzimi
di cui parlavo prima.
Sono enzimi particolari, questi:
sono enzimi che sono
in grado di metabolizzare
sostanze che noi
introduciamo con la dieta,
ma soprattutto sono in grado
di metabolizzare farmaci.
È questo che mi interessa.
Quindi io, quando prendo un farmaco,
il primo passaggio del farmaco,
a livello epatico,
lo fa metabolizzare un po'.
Poi il resto del farmaco
passa, va in circolo,
va naturalmente dove deve andare
per compiere la sua missione.
Allora al farmacologo, prima di tutto,
quali geni interessano
perché è lì che dobbiamo
cercare le variazioni.
Beh, prima di tutto i farmaci agiscono
perché interagiscono fisicamente
con dei bersagli molecolari.
Per esempio, l'aspirina
blocca la cicloossigenasi.
Allora a noi interessano
le variazioni nei geni
che codificano per i bersagli
dell'azione dei farmaci.
E poi, ed è di questo
che soprattutto vi parlerò,
ci interessano moltissimo i geni
che codificano per le proteine
coinvolte nel metabolismo dei farmaci,
che come vedremo, sono prevalentemente
localizzate a livello epatico.
E poi, naturalmente,
abbiamo visto che questa -
che questo farmaco ha dovuto
attraversare l'intestino;
se dovesse entrare nel cervello
dovrebbe attraversare
la barriera ematoencefalica,
quindi deve attraversare
delle barriere biologiche,
e per fare questo
utilizza dei trasportatori
che possono essere diversi
da individuo ad individuo.
Allora che cos'è la farmacogenetica?
Di che cosa ci stiamo occupando?
La farmacogenetica è la disciplina
che studia le basi genetiche
della risposta individuale ai farmaci.
Vediamo un po' più da vicino
questi enzimi epatici di cui si parlava.
Beh, un ruolo fondamentale,
nel metabolismo dei farmaci
a livello epatico
lo gioca la superfamiglia
del citocromo P450.
Si tratta di un'ottantina di geni,
e altrettante proteine,
in realtà non tutte coinvolte
nel metabolismo dei farmaci,
alcune di queste sono coinvolte
anche nel metabolismo di altre sostanze,
ma, insomma, sono enzimi
assolutamente fondamentali,
perché la loro professione principale,
poi vedremo che ne hanno anche un'altra,
è quella, sostanzialmente,
di distruggere, metabolizzare,
degradare il farmaco.
Questa è una bella sicurezza per noi,
perché sappiamo
che somministriamo il farmaco,
ma sappiamo che
non resterà all'interno
dell'organismo per sempre,
perché c'è un meccanismo che è in grado,
appunto, di degradarlo,
e poi il farmaco verrà eliminato
per via urinaria o per via biliare.
Io mi soffermerò un attimino
su questo citocromo,
il citocromo P450 2D6,
che è molto, molto interessante
perché presenta una serie di polimorfismi.
Prima di tutto, presenta quel fenomeno
della copy number variation,
cioè vuol dire che ci sono
alcuni individui
che hanno zero copie
del citocromo P450 2D6,
e ci sono individui che hanno
fino a 13 copie perfettamente funzionanti;
soggetti che non metabolizzano
i farmaci via 2D6,
e soggetti che li metabolizzano troppo.
A proposito di migrazione
delle popolazioni,
guardate questa mappa del pianeta.
La maggior parte dei soggetti
con questo tipo di duplicazione,
di copy number variation,
è localizzato in Arabia Saudita
e in Eritrea, circa il 30 percento.
Poi c'è l'Europa con - in realtà
questi dati sono ancora ottimistici -
circa il 20 percento dei soggetti
è portatore di questa
copy number variation.
Ma il dato interessante
è che in Europa compare
dopo l'800 dopo Cristo,
cioè, in altre parole,
coincide con la migrazione degli Arabi
nel nostro continente.
Gli Arabi, venendosene fuori
da queste zone,
portano questo tipo di polimorfismo
incrociandosi, naturalmente, sempre,
appunto, con le nostre antenate.
E oggi abbiamo il 20 percento di soggetti
che sono portatori in Europa
di questa copy number variation.
Adesso vediamo, da un punto
di vista pratico
che cosa vuol dire avere zero copie,
o tre copie, o tredici copie di enzima.
Questo è un esperimento molto semplice.
Soggetti volontari -
che poi sono studenti di medicina
che magari volontari non sono,
ma sono, naturalmente, sani -
che sono stati caratterizzati
per il numero di copie funzionanti
che hanno del 2D6,
e poi è stato fatto un esperimento banale.
Una compressina da 25 milligrammi
di nortriptilina,
un antidepressivo triciclico,
e poi si fa un esperimento facile:
si preleva dal torrente ematico,
con un prelievo di sangue, nel tempo
e si va a misurare
la concentrazione del farmaco.
Allora cosa mi aspetto,
da un soggetto che ha
due copie funzionali di 2D6?
Beh, ho un picco - lo vedete,
questo qua in rosso, vedete -
al picco aumenta la concentrazione;
poi, progressivamente,
la concentrazione del farmaco scende.
Perché il farmaco continua
a ripassare dal fegato,
e viene distrutto.
Dopo 72 ore, il farmaco non c'è più.
Ma il soggetto, invece,
che ha zero copie funzionali,
come si comporterà ?
Questo soggetto qua, in grigio, vedete,
ha una concentrazione plasmatica al picco
che subito, d'emblée,
è il doppio rispetto al soggetto
che metabolizza con due geni;
e dopo 72 ore,
è ancora pieno di nortriptilina,
perché non la metabolizza.
Questi soggetti, nella vita reale,
vanno in pronto soccorso
a causa degli effetti avversi
del trattamento farmacologico,
che dà cardiotossicità.
Ma il problema qual è?
È che loro non metabolizzano il farmaco.
E i nostri amici arabi?
Sono questi qua.
Metabolizzano il farmaco
alla velocità della luce!
Hanno 13 copie funzionali.
Fallimenti terapeutici!
Gli psichiatri lo sanno benissimo,
qual è il loro problema
con i loro farmaci.
Accanto al poster dell'uomo nero,
nel loro studio, hanno il poster del 2D6,
perché questo gli cambia tantissimo
il metabolismo dei farmaci.
Non vi spaventate!
(Risate)
Il messaggio è una cosa molto semplice:
i farmaci non vengono, sempre,
introdotti come tali.
Qualche volta vengono introdotti
come profarmaci, cioè non sono attivi,
e hanno bisogno proprio
del sistema dei citocromi
per essere attivati
e diventare delle molecole attive.
Allora guardate soltanto qua: la codeina,
un farmaco analgesico,
che tutti conoscete.
Non funziona, la codeina,
perché ha questo gruppo CH3,
che i chimici chiamano gruppo metilico,
che le impedisce di interagire
con il suo bersaglio molecolare.
Ci pensa il 2D6 a rimuovere il gruppo CH3,
e a trasformare la codeina in morfina.
La morfina sì, che funziona!
Ma il punto è, se io ho un soggetto
che ha zero copie funzionali di 2D6,
cosa gli succede
quando gli do il profarmaco?
Allora, questo è il soggetto normale.
Io gli do la codeina e misuro la morfina.
Vedete, la concentrazione
ematica di morfina sale,
poi scende perché viene
metabolizzata da altri sistemi.
Il soggetto con zero copie funzionali
non converte la codeina in morfina.
È un fallimento terapeutico.
È inutile dargli quel farmaco,
perché tanto non lo convertirà.
C'è un altro analgesico che si comporta
sostanzialmente in questa maniera,
ed è il tramadolo,
anche lui deve essere attivato.
Questi sono i soggetti
che non metabolizzano -
sono i cosiddetti poor metabolizer -
non hanno 2D6, non convertono
il tramadolo nella forma attiva.
Zero risposta.
Ma questi sono i nostri amici Arabi,
13 copie funzionali,
conversione totale del tramadolo
in farmaco attivo:
in coma, intossicazione da oppiacei;
o, se hanno meno numeri di copie,
"Dottore, l'altra sera ho visto
gli ippogrifi sui muri.
Non mi dia più il farmaco che mi ha dato."
Allucinazioni, ok?
Molte delle diverse risposte
che noi abbiamo
sono in realtà dovute
al differente assetto genetico.
Vi sto facendo soltanto vedere
l'aspetto del metabolismo.
Ci sarebbe da ridere se vi facessi vedere,
per esempio, i bersagli molecolari.
In Europa ci sono cinquanta milioni
di individui così ripartiti:
20-30 milioni che non hanno 2D6,
e 15-20 milioni che ne hanno troppo,
che hanno problemi a metabolizzare farmaci
attraverso questo citocromo.
Tenete presente
che tutti i farmaci psicoattivi
praticamente vengono metabolizzati
dal citocromo P450 2D6.
In Italia ci sono 5.7 milioni di individui
che hanno duplicazione del 2D6.
Chissà quanti tra di voi
hanno duplicazione del 2D6!
Allora, sostanzialmente,
a che punto siamo
con questa farmacogenetica?
Beh, la farmacogenetica è un processo
che si sviluppa,
sostanzialmente, in tre fasi.
La fase della scoperta
e della catalogazione dei polimorfismi
è stata fatta in parte
dal Progetto Genoma Umano,
ma soprattutto da progetti successivi.
Noi oggi sappiamo perfettamente
dove si trovano i diversi
polimorfismi nel nostro genoma.
Poi siamo in una fase,
siamo immersi in questa fase:
la ricerca delle correlazioni.
È quella reazione avversa
correlata a quel polimorfismo
nel 2D6 oppure no?
Ma la terza fase, che è già partita,
è la fase diagnostica.
Perché tutto questo discorso,
perché ci interessa?
Perché noi possiamo, a priori,
stabilire quante copie voi avete di 2D6,
e stabilire quanto farmaco darvi,
o non darvi per niente quel farmaco
e darvene un altro.
Cioè diventa una componente fondamentale,
la farmacogenetica,
di quel processo che è la cosiddetta
"personalizzazione della terapia".
L'ho chiamato processo
perché è una tendenza
della medicina occidentale.
Questa è una review
tratta da una rivista che si chiama
"Nature Review Drug Discovery";
quindi, capite bene,
è una rivista che si occupa
dei farmaci del futuro: drug discovery.
Però ha sentito l'esigenza, assolutamente,
di interrogarsi su come noi usiamo
i farmaci del presente.
E questo è il riassunto
di quello che pensa questo reviewer.
Questa è la situazione attuale:
un gruppo di pazienti,
tutti quanti con la stessa patologia,
li trattiamo tutti con lo stesso farmaco,
o con gli stessi farmaci,
allo stesso dosaggio,
e in risultato finale che cosa otteniamo?
Che, veramente bene,
ne curiamo soltanto una frazione,
perché alcuni di questi
avranno reazioni avverse,
altri avranno fallimenti terapeutici,
dovranno continuamente aggiustare la dose.
Questa è la situazione futura:
a ciascun gruppo di pazienti
il farmaco giusto al dosaggio giusto:
cioè, ripeto ancora una volta,
personalizzazione della terapia.
Il grande sogno
della medicina occidentale.
Allora io sono fermamente convinto
che la farmacogenetica
sia uno strumento potentissimo
che ci aiuterà a realizzare
questo grandissimo sogno.
Grazie.
(Applausi)